when you first Drew Beavis and Butthead
what did you have are you copying a
person are you is it somebody you knew
well see I'm not very good at drawing so
it started out as
two different attempts to draw the same
person
so yeah like I was I was trying so and
he was a guy who's nothing like Beavis
and Butthead he was a uh
it's actually a straight A student nerd
he's a I shouldn't say what he is now no
he's an engineer what's his name you
were an engineer right yeah I can't say
uh you can't yeah I probably shouldn't
well but can I just say something before
you say you probably shouldn't don't you
think that if if you told me that I was
the impetus for Beavis and Butthead you
don't think that's a compliment you
wouldn't sue me or well he wasn't really
the he was very look the only thing well
it started see what happened is
I was trying to draw him and it sort of
went it's like that doesn't quite look
like him but I like what it looks like I
think the first one was uh what's his
name was Beavis
I want to know his name is it was uh
something like uh Bob or Steve now Bob
and Steve are listening going it's me
you've just made a thousand ten thousand
Bobs and Steve but he was like he was a
uh
he was
I've told the story before but I'll tell
you I'll tell you the different version
We you tell me a different version I'll
tell you that I'm getting the better
version okay and we had a it was
Calculus class senior year we had this
uh
a new teacher well this guy comes up to
like I'm passing this guy in the hallway
my my friend Tim Niecy and he goes uh
he said oh my God have you seen the
calculus teachers she's hot maybe it's
junior year she's like
she's super hot and I was like no I've
there's never been a hot teacher at the
school that's not well she was like a
former Dallas Cowboys Cheerleader and
really everyone was freaked out but this
one kid he sat in front and he was he
was just he would laugh at everything
she said and she hardly ever said
anything funny but he would just sit
there writing really fasting
he's like biting his lip in this kind of
nerdy way going
and uh I would imitate him in the back
of class and these guys sitting next to
me started imitating him too and it was
super annoying to the teacher and
um does he know who he is uh does he
know who he is no do you does the world
know who that guy is that had that laugh
a couple friends of mine do he probably
does he might I don't know will you say
his name oh no I I uh he's a nuclear
engineer now
he's in charge of uh safety no I don't
actually don't know so that's where this
is but that was just a sound but when I
was trying to draw him it didn't look
like that but it looked like something
else the Beavis the blonde-haired one
was the first one I did and
I sort of exaggerated it to look more
like I didn't know who but not anyone I
knew specifically at all it was just
sort of like
I just imagine it was kind of influenced
by all kinds of people and I drew a
lighter in his hand and I just imagined
him kind of going lighting a lighter I
don't know maybe a little bit of a Texas
Chainsaw Massacre inspired you know all
those I love that I love I gotta say
that your characters and and I think
you've told the story Ad nauseam so many
times but I'm fascinated by your whole
story
um are you in good terms of Francesca oh
yeah yeah okay so Francesca is his wife
his ex-wife and and we were all
neighbors we were all neighbors and for
your birthday right you were you were
are you already an engineer were you
still in school
oh I don't know it depends on which uh
oh just the whole beginning
they gave you she bought you an
animation at home animation kit right oh
not really I mean she bought me she she
had bought me a
that the story I might have told you was
uh I mean I was already deciding
everybody different story no I I there
was no kid because that that got into
the New York Times the guy summed it up
but there was no kid I I just bought
some supplies with the catalog I think
but but you know yeah we were together
we didn't have kids yet and I just
decided I was going to give this a try
because I'd seen
um at there was a it's called the
animation celebration that would every
year this company would put in Indie
movie theaters a compilation of all the
oscar-nominated shorts around the world
and just shorts that got into this
Festival do you have epilepsy uh no no
because the the lights are flickering
no no no no I just don't want you to
have a seizure oh no I'm fine okay uh
but yeah so so that was that was like uh
I don't know um
a a local guy we lived in outside of
Dallas and a guy had gotten a film in
there this guy Paul Claire so but yeah
but so yeah no she was so this was very
supportive she she one thing she got me
from my birthday was a little uh it was
a little Pink Panther thing where you
could it's one of those just toys where
you'd see the film I might have told you
about that and you could step through
it's a really good way to kind of but
your first was your first one frog
baseball it's frog no the first one I
did was actually called office space and
it which later led to the movie but it
was yeah it was just uh the character
Milton and the boss Lumberg taking a
stapler it was a two minute short right
I've said that's what yeah that's what
started everything for me because I
I animated the whole thing with yeah
with the stuff I bought from a catalog
cartoon color company I think it's still
there
um so now aren't you you're mentioning
them don't you think that they're gonna
come after you we started this
but that was you don't sue me I will
never sue you buddy but I found it
fascinating that this was like just a
side hobby you you uh entered a local
Animation Festival and then I remember
Mike's who's the guy that worked with
Mike that came out to Texas and saw you
and and helped you sell it to liquid
television what was his name oh someone
who came to Texas who was who who
originally found you before from from
three Arts oh well rotenberg I had
already gotten my stuff Michael
rotenberg uh so that happened
just kind of networking I was a musician
at the time actually you still are yeah
but I was playing with a guy Doyle
Bramhall it was my only I couldn't get a
lawyer to call me back like I so I had
the fourth short I did was Beavis and
butted right and that was in these
festivals
um
the the Spike and Mike festival and
animation celebration and so I was
getting some and I I just like mailed
VHS tapes to these people I didn't have
any connections but by then I was
starting to get some and anyway that
yeah rotenberg saw a tape of
um five shorts and signed me right I had
a deal to do Beavis and butted we were
in production on the show but it hadn't
gone on The Air I remember when he saw
them and I remember the VHS you know
Michael and I have been friends yes we
were 13 years old like High School area
yeah and you're still you said I was a
musician you don't consider yourself a
musician at all I guess I I mean I did
it for a living back then yeah yeah I
still I still play yeah do you put the
music are you involved in any of the
music in your movies and TV shows uh
yeah I mean well there's a mostly I use
this really great composer John Frizzell
I've used some but I I mean the Beavis
About It theme song is was always me
playing all the instruments I I just
recently for the new series redid it
with uh Glenn Paramount plus Paramount
plus Gary Clark Jr
um it was really awesome he he did uh he
did a version I'm I'm playing on it too
but but he's he's amazing I still love
music yeah
yeah I mean I think I think if I was a
if I was a really good singer I wouldn't
be doing any of this I just if I had a
really great voice I would just do
nothing else how do you know you don't
you know what I'm I've tried can I have
a good voice for doing stupid laughs no
better than me I've been asking this may
be uncomfortable yeah I want you I know
because I'm a talent judge so just this
is yeah
sing something and I'll I'll tell you
whether you have you don't want to sing
for me well you know I did sing as
Beavis the uh I got you babe
and I uh it was a hit believe it or not
because of Cher but uh
foreign
[Music]